[Music]
hey guys George Campbell here with
another minute money hack now being on
camera all the time means I need to be
full of energy and by full of energy I
mean full of caffeine so I'm here at you
guessed its Starbucks today I'm gonna
teach you how to live your best
Starbucks life and save some caffeine
coin now if you're already commenting
saying oh won't you just go brew coffee
at home and save all the money we'll
just skip the comment and go grind your
own beans because we got work to do here
people so let's get to it
for starters make sure your Rewards
member rewards that's such a weird word
posit [ __ ] rewards there we go you can
get free refills on brewed coffee and
tea in store a free drink on your
birthday and more pro tip I love using
the app to order ahead and avoid the
line did you know there's an even
smaller cup than at all it's called a
short when you order a short espresso
drink you'll get the same amount of
caffeine as at all while paying less
just looking for that caffeine boost
switch to brewed coffee here's why a
tall coffee has more caffeine than a
venti latte and it's half the price if
you just really need that iced latte fix
here's how to get one on the cheap order
a double espresso over ice in a venti
cup then head over to the bar area and
add your own milk bingo you've got your
own cheap lot a bonus hack got your dog
with you order a puppet Chino and you'll
get a sample sized cup of whipped cream
that your dog will love plus it's super
cute to watch oh and remember to tip
your baristas well folks and there's
your minute money heck
[Music]